the second woman
who was urged by Herschel Walker to get
an abortion has now come forward to
explain that Herschel Walker threatened
suicide after impregnating her now it's
so hard to keep track of this you might
remember there was the first woman who
said Herschel Walker urged me to have an
abortion and I got it and then he urged
me to have another abortion and I
refused and then we had a kid that's
woman number one
then we had woman number two represented
by attorney Gloria Allred woman number
two said he urged me to have an abortion
and I did it I believe that this woman
that we were talking about today is
woman number two although the reporting
is a little unclear and this may be a
third woman but I'm pretty sure it's
that second woman listen to this 1893 93
she learned that Mr Walker had
impregnated her
my client did not want to have an
abortion
when she told Mr Walker about the
pregnancy he spoke about disappearing
and he quote afterlife end quote and
made her believe
that he might commit suicide can you
imagine this level of manipulation
he also claimed that if she gave birth
both our client and their child would be
in danger
Jane Doe stated that she felt pressured
by Mr Walker's threats and went alone to
the abortion clinic
to have the procedure
but she left crying because she did not
want to go through with it
after she told Mr Walker that she did
not have the abortion
she stated that the next day Mr Walker
drove her in his car to the abortion
clinic to ensure that she had the
abortion
that she did not want to have Wilson
I'm sure
there are more details to all of these
stories and also stories we haven't
heard at the end of the day there are
many reasons not to vote for Herschel
Walker his extreme personal hypocrisy on
a lot of these political issues is one
reason his complete lack of morals is
another reason
his inability to explain what his
policies would be is another reason his
lack of understanding of policy is
another reason and also the fact that
Raphael Warnock is a pretty damn good
Senator there is already someone doing
that job who is doing a pretty good job
everyone must vote on December 6th or
during early voting if you live in
Georgia we will be live with those
results and just the situation gets more
disgusting just about every day I love
cooking at home I cook all the time
having a good set of knives that you
actually like to use is really important
for years I have been a fan of the
advantages that Japanese knives offer
and our sponsor kamikodo makes amazing
Japanese steel kitchen knives using the
traditional techniques that date back to
the Edo period of Japan kamikoto only
uses steel from Japan each blade takes
years to craft and goes through a
rigorous 19-step inspection process with
a lifetime guarantee the knives come in
a beautiful heavy duty Ash wood box
makes it a really great gift easy to
store as well on the kamikota website
you can see a map of the Michelin star
chefs all over the world you using
kamikoto knives my kamikoto knives at
home have been performing great for
years you really just can't beat the
feel of a nice Japanese knife perfectly
balanced in your hand and kamikoto is
now running a big Black Friday sale my
audience gets an extra fifty dollars off
go to kamikodo.com Pacman and use the
code Pacman the link is down below